les États-Unis sur plusieurs fronts
renforcent leur trac du réseau
terroriste d'Ousama Ben Laden avec un
succès certain ces derniers semaine
ainsi l'arrestation la semaine dernière
du financier et du stratège de
l'organisation réfugié au Pakistan et
bien cette arrestation cette double
arrestation a été rendue possible grâce
d'abord à des moyens technologiques
impressionnants auquel il faut ajouter
pour la première fois l' pas du gain 25
millions de dollars pour celui qui les a
dénoncé Richard Binet Bernard
puiss l'État américain s'apprête à
signer un chèque de 25 millions de
dollars la récompense offerte par le FBI
pour la capture de Ralet cher Mohamed 38
ans considéré comme le cerveau des
principaux attentats commis par
Al-Qaïda selon la version officielle la
traque a commencé il y a quelques mois
très loin du Pakistan près de
Washington dans les bureaux de la NSA
l'Agence nationale de sécurité
américaines des ordinateurs parmi les
plus puissants du monde analyse les
communications interceptées par
satellite c'est le système échelon
toujours selon les autorités américaines
cher Mohamed possédait 10 portables
qu'il utilisait
fréquemment cela aurait permis de
localiser l'un de ses interlocuteurs à
cueta au Pakistan un Égyptien que les
services secrets ont convaincu de
coopérer moyenne en récompense 25
millions de dollars plus une rallonge de
2 millions pour se rendre en
Grande-Bretagne une version un peu trop
belle pour être vrai selon les
spécialistes du renseignement ce sont
surtout les services secrets pakistanais
qui ont aidé à sa
ils ont une connaissance très précise
factuelle des lieux de cache des modes
de communication comment ces gens-là
opèent donc ce type de renseignement est
beaucoup plus déterminant pour arrêter
quelqu'un du calibre de RAL cher Mohamed
que de penser qu'il va se trahir par son
vulgaire téléphone portable grand mérite
de la version officielle elle évite au
Pakistan d'apparaître en première ligne
dans l'arrestation de cher Mohamed et
peut faire douter Al-Qaïda de la totale
fidélité de ses trou